bonjour je vous dis bonjour mais en fait
je ne sais pas qui vous êtes
d'ailleurs je meurs d'envié de vous le
demander à chacun d'entre vous mais vous
êtes 900 alors ça prendrait un peu de
temps qui vous seriez peut-être pas
hyper à l'aise de dire qui vous êtes
devant 200 personnes
mais bon imaginez imaginons que je sois
seul avec chacun d'entre vous tranquille
à dire on est en tête à tête
peut-être je sais pas dans un restaurant
en tenez au bord de l'eau un peu plus
loin et je vous pose la question qui
êtes vous franchement qu'est ce que vous
pourriez me répondre peut-être me donnez
votre nom je suis jean dupont isabelle
durand hockey et vos parents auraient pu
choisir un autre prénom vous transmettre
un autre nom vous est et un autre pour
autant pouvez-vous définir aussi par
votre profession je suis commercial
comptable secrétaire ingénieurs hockey
et vous auriez pu choisir un autre
métier n'est ce pas seriez-vous
quelqu'un d'autre pour autant alors vous
pouvez vous définir par une qualité peut
être je suis quelqu'un de gentil ville
créative fort oui et peut-être que votre
voisin exactement les mêmes qualités
tout en mettant une autre personne n'est
ce pas en fait vous pourriez même pas
vous définir par vos gènes parce que si
vous aviez un frère jumeau ou une soeur
jumelle eh bien il aurait exactement le
même patrimoine génétique que vous tout
en mettant une autre personne
alors qui êtes vous
moi quand j'avais 23 ans je me suis
retrouvé mon bac + 5 en poche le
propulser au sein de la direction
financière d'une grande entreprise et je
me suis avec mes homologues étaient très
très fier d'eux de ce poste ce type de
poste valorisant
moi il m'a suffi de quelques semaines
pour réaliser que je m'étais fourvoyer
dans une voie qui n'était pas la mienne
est un mot que je vous dis ça parce
qu'en fait quand les journalistes
m'interrogent ils veulent entendre
parler l'auteur à succès d'accord il
veut m'entendre parler des succès
littéraires mais la vérité tout à fait
entre nous ça va pas sortir d'ici c'est
j'ai connu dans ma vie beaucoup plus
d'échecs et même d' humiliations que de
succès est-ce que personne ne sait c'est
que ce sont ses échecs et ses
humiliations qui paradoxalement m'ont
sauvé la vie en fait ils m'ont aidé à
savoir qui je suis et de là tout a
découlé pour moi là quand j'avais 23 ans
je vous disais j'ai réalisé subitement
que j'ai des fours voyant une voie qui
n'était pas la mienne et partant de là
et bien je suis en effet allé d'échec en
échec de poste en poste j'ai erré
pendant des années jusqu'à finir par me
faire licencier ou quand on n'aime pas
ce qu'on fait en général on on n'est pas
très bon donc je me suis retrouvé au
chômage
là j'en souris mais j'avais tellement
honte que je les cache et à tous mes
amis de même caché ma famille et je suis
resté deux ans au chômage
je savais plus quoi faire de ma vie j'ai
fait une dépression
j'ai perdu 10 kilos mon métier m'avait
échappé et mon corps semble m échapper
aussi la nature m'a donné ce corps trop
trop grand trop trop étroit un corps
dont je tentais de dissimuler la
maigreur autrefois dans des vêtements
amples alors par chance c'était les
années 80 rappelez vous c'était la mode
des vestes large avec les épaulettes
ultra rembourré j'ai adoré cette mode
j'ai prié pour qu'elle dure et ça pas
été le cas alors je me suis inscrit dans
une salle de musculation
bien décidé à développer trois
centimètres deltoïde sur chaque épaule
et falloir plusieurs mois plusieurs mois
j'étais sur des engins de torture et je
regardais personne je me suis vraiment
dans ma bulle je ne vous les croisez
aucun regard j'étais toujours pétri de
route et vous vous demandez peut-être
pourquoi je vous raconte salah est ce
que en fait c'est difficile pour
beaucoup d'entre nous de savoir qui on
est et voyez vous moi on sait qu'ils ont
en eux et plus on a envie d'exister
alors on s'accroche à tout ce qui peut
nous valoriser des images des apparences
des rôles
par exemple on peut s'accrocher à son
rôle professionnel est un t2 de
s'identifier à son métier d'exister à
travers son métier
aujourd'hui je suis écrivain je pourrais
essayer d'exister à travers ce métier
d'écrivain et à ce moment là je jouerai
à un rôle d'écrivain je me mettrai à
parler comme un écrivain adopter des
attitudes d'écrivains peut-être un look
d'écrivain si je sais pas trop à quoi ça
correspond et le problème c'est que si
j'allais dans cette direction en fait
plus je ferai ça et puis je mens
fermerait dans une représentation de moi
même
kim éloignerait de qui je suis parce que
qui je suis pas bien au delà de mon
simple métier d'écrivain qui vous n'êtes
pas bien au delà de votre métier
on peut s'identifier aussi on peut
s'accrocher à sur l'apparence physique
ça arrive fréquemment aux femmes et aux
hommes doté d'un physique avantageux qui
peuvent à ce moment là chercher à
exister à travers leur beauté d'accord
et à ce moment là en fait c'est lié à un
sentiment que
leur valeur repose sur leur beauté alors
qu'en fait elle n'est qu'un attribut
c'est pas conscient d'ailleurs il ya un
moyen de savoir si c'est le cas pour
vous ces cas là vous vous sentez
amoindrie en présence d'une personne
plus belle que vous si on vante la
beauté de quelqu'un d'autre alors que
mais un peu comme si vous aviez le
sentiment que cette personne existe plus
que vous mais c'est complètement
inconscient la vérité est que votre
valeur va bien au delà de votre beauté
on peut s'identifier aussi à son
intelligence sa culture ses idées et
tenter d'exister à travers ses propos et
à ce moment là on se sent plutôt
amoindri parce que quelqu'un vous
contredis vous dit quelque chose
là vous vous sentez attaqué
personnellement alors que la personne en
fait a juste exprimé un désaccord sur
vos idées on peut aussi s'accrocher à
ses possessions et croire que notre
valeur découle de ce que nous avons des
choses que nous avons notre voiture
notre maison un téléphone portable à sac
à main et à ce moment là on se sent se
sont amoindris en présence d'une
personne qui a une plus belle voiture
plus belles maisons plus beaux sacs beau
téléphone
moi quand j'étais enfin le problème en
fait si vous voulez par rapport à toutes
ces fausses représentations de soi même
c'est qu'elle nous éloigne de qui on est
et nous éloigne de clooney et donc d'une
certaine façon on risque de se perdre à
travers ces fausses représentations
moi quand j'étais en dépression j'avais
perdu mais naturellement par la force
des choses toutes ses représentations et
je le vivais comme le problème à
l'époque c'est là je ne pouvais me
raccrocher à rien parce que tout se
dérobait sous mes pieds et en fait il
s'est passé un phénomène étonnant c'est
que quand je me suis retrouvé nu j'ai
envie de dire sans s'employer en
valorisant à comment reprendre me
raccrocher j'avais plus d'existence
professionnels j'étais gaulé comme un
haricot vert je possède est rien même
pas une voiture est néanmoins j'ai
réalisé que
j'existais toujours bien de le dire mais
voilà je j'existais toujours j'avais
plus rien mais j'ai existait toujours
cela fait un drôle de sentiment et je me
suis mis à regarder autour de moi et au
club de musculation
je suis rendu compte que les membres du
club sont répartis en deux catégories en
fait il y avait les maigrichon honteux
comme moi et puis il y avait les musclés
et là j'ai découvert que la salle était
constellée de miroirs pourtant je la
fréquente et depuis plusieurs mois mais
je vous ai dit j'étais dans ma bulle
elle était constellée de miroirs et les
muscles et faisait leur exercice en
scène me rend devant le miroir
en fait c'était pire que ça faisait 2 il
était en admiration devant leur corps
ils étaient amoureux de leur propre
corps on frôlait l'autoérotisme cette
vision m'a libéré en fait je suis
réalisé ce jour là que leur narcissisme
et ma honte étaient les deux faces d'une
même pièce en fait les deux faces d'une
même croyance que notre valeur se mesure
à l'aune de notre apparence ce jour là
j'ai viré mais veste large et lorsque je
me suis retrouvée nue comme ça se sent
plus rien de valorisant auquel me
raccrocher eh bien il ya des choses qui
ont émergé ans - l'âge et je me suis mis
à ressentir des envies de ce que j'avais
envie de faire dans la vie il ya non
plus des choses valorisante mais les
choses que mon père mon coeur nous
poussait à suivre comme par exemple le
métier de formateur un métier que j'ai
exercé ensuite pendant une bonne dizaine
d'années ça peut vous faire sourire mais
dans ma famille d'intellectuels
scientifique formateur c'était un petit
métier vraiment mais je me souviens
comme si c'était hier du jour où j'ai
décidé de devenir formateur et on je
renonçais être reconnue notamment de mes
parents et c'était coûteux pour moi
c'est coûteux mais je je l'accepté
pleinement j'acceptais sereinement et en
renonçant à la reconnaissance
en fait j'ai obtenu l'épanouissement
sur le fronton du temple d'apollon
adelphe je vous en ai sur les chemins de
la sagesse d'apollon adelphe il y avait
deux préceptes de près 7 alors il y en a
un que tout le monde connaît quand il
est célèbre
c'est le fameux connais toi toi même qui
était repris par socrate tout le monde
le connaît me alain deuxième que le
monde entier semble avoir oublié celui
là fait rien de trop
rien de trop il ya 2500 ans les sages de
la grèce antique nous inviter à nous
connaître et ne pas se prendre pour ce
que l'on n'est pas à partir de là tout a
été simple dans ma vie à partir du
moment où j'ai cessé de jouer un rôle de
chercher à valoriser les portes se sont
ouvertes comme par magie mais les
clients sont venus à moi
les contrats ne sont tombés du ciel et
lorsque je pars à 10 ou 12 ans plus tard
j'ai senti monter en moi l'appel de
l'écriture j'ai trouvé un éditeur en
quinze jours je pense que ce qui peut
vous arriver de plus de plus beau de
plus précieux dans la vie c'est de
réaliser que vous êtes autre chose que
de fausses identités et renoncer à vous
valoriser à travers elle alors pour
santé peut-être à cette idée une espèce
de 2 g pas de vertiges de peur du vide
vous vous dites peut-être oui ok
d'accord mais bon si je cesse de soi ni
moi ni ma fille je cesse de mettre en
avant mon métier mes qualités mes
possessions mes relations enfin bref
tout ce qui me valorise soit qu'est ce
qui reste
qui vous dit peut-être aussi finalement
pas je serai je ré ignorez peut-être
même méprisé on remarque plus est en
fait voyez vous la vérité à l'opposé
parce qu'on vous existerait enfin parce
que vous êtes réellement
est ce que vous êtes réellement est
infiniment plus grand plus beau plus
profond
tout ce à quoi vous avez pu vous
accrocher jusque là en fait notre simple
présence et d'une grande valeur et n'a
pas besoin d'être enjolivé d'une façon
ou d'une autre la société de
consommation on essaye de vous faire
croire qu'il vous manque quelque chose
mais la vérité est que non vous êtes
complet et en lâchant prise sur ces
fausses identités
vous avez ressenti est ce que j'ai
ressenti être des choses vont émerger en
vous des envies de ce que vous voulez
faire de votre vie et cette fois ci ce
sera non plus des désirs inculquée par
la publicité mais des envies véritable
de ce que vous voulez faire de votre vie
des choses qui viendront du plus profond
de vous même vous vous dites peut-être
aussi ok très bien mais comment je fais
pour me libérer de ces fausses
d'identité et qui qui peut vous rassurer
et quelque part pour moi je vous en ai
parlé c'est parti de certains échecs
cuisants et on vous n'êtes pas obligé
d'en passer par là
en fait bon après moi j vous un travail
sur moi j'ai eu des vous des voyages des
rencontres avec le cep a décidé d'aider
sage des philosophes l'âme des chamans
et aujourd'hui vous y avez avec le recul
finalement ce que j'en retire c'est
qu'il n'y a pas un seul chemin vers la
découverte de soi même la cie de la peur
de ne pas être reconnu de ne pas exister
à la confiance en soi la confiance dans
la vie cette confiance
on la trouve quand on la prend assez
mais véritablement quand on apprend à
aimer ce que l'on est quand on est nu
sans et bien à ce moment là on n'a plus
besoin de de revêtir une image ou
d'endosser un rôle
cette confiance on la trouve aussi quand
on apprend à accepter l'échec c'est pas
dans notre culture
en occident on a tendance à vouloir
réussir tous à tout prix est en fait
vous voyez quand on accepte ses failles
ses faiblesses ses fragilités et bien
petit à petit ça nous aide à trouver le
bon endroit pour nous à trouver notre
place quoi l'échec en fête permet
d'expérimenter la vie alors que la
réussite vous pousse à vous identifier
au succès et donc que vous perdre la
confiance en la vie quand on la trouve
je dirais en
s'exerçant la gratitude en cultivant un
ressenti de gratitude dans notre pays on
a plutôt tendance à râler contre les
événements à être déçu de ce qui va pas
dans notre vie mais si vous prenez
l'habitude de mettre votre attention sur
ce qui vous arrive de bien dans votre
vie et vous arrive forcément tous les
jours des choses bien même si c'est
quelques instants chaque jour donc
malgré les difficultés malgré vos
problèmes si vous mettez votre attention
sur ce qui vous arrive de bien et bien
vous allez développer
vous allez ouvrir votre esprit est ce
qui vient elle devait les ouvrir votre
coeur à ce que la vie va vous offrir
quand même si vous remercier la vie pour
cela vous ressentirez cet état de
gratitude et en s'exerçant à la
gratitude
on passe du statut de déçus à celui de
béni et une fois que que cette confiance
en fait est atteinte et bien devient
libre libre du regard des autres libres
d'agir en son âme et conscience et il se
passe alors un phénomène qui est assez
étonnant c'est qu'on s'intéresse moins
sa personne en fait c'est juste que l'on
s'est connecté à quelque chose de plus
grand que soi
alors j'ai juste envie de vous dire
aller à leur rencontre de votre propre
chemin aller dans cette direction parce
que c'est à ce moment là que la vie
prend son véritable sens bonne route
mais année